rufen Sie auf den straßenpalermos aus
Protest gegen ein Vorhaben der Regierung
melonis Italiens Rechte Regierungschefin
will den redito dicita-dinanza das Hartz
IV ähnliche bürgereinkommen weitgehend
streichen wir haben immer gesagt dass
Bürger Einkommen ist falsch ein
gerechter Staat sollte diejenigen die
arbeiten könnten nicht auf eine Stufe
stellen mit wirklich Bedürftigen
die 53-Jährige Anzahl und judische lebt
von dem Bürgergeld noch denn wir
zwischen 18 und 60 Jahre alt ist und
nicht krank oder Mutter solle doch
lieber arbeiten statt staatliches Geld
zu beziehen so die neue Rechte Regierung
Enza hat in ihrem Leben viel gearbeitet
lange Zeit war sie in einer Schuhfabrik
angestellt dann wurde sie in der
Wirtschaftskrise entlassen war ohne
Einkommen sie zeigt uns wo sie danach
arbeitete als schuhputzerin
ich habe hier nicht viel verdient das
kriegt man in diesem Beruf nicht so 15
bis 20 Euro am Tag abhängig von den
Leuten die vorbei kam
sie gab die Arbeit auf weil sie ihre
kranke Mutter pflegen musste Dank
bürgereinkommen konnte sie der Armut
entrinnen 780 € erhält sie doch sie hat
Angst was passiert wenn es abgeschafft
wird Ihre Wohnung alleine kostet kalt
330 € und Arbeit gibt es kaum
vor kurzem habe ich einen Kurs gemacht
und habe nach einer Woche ein Zertifikat
erworben es war ein mehrzweckkurs in
einem Hotel
was bieten sie dir am Ende sie bieten
dir 500 Euro pro Monat ohne Vertrag
schwarz
von den zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen
die auf das bürgereinkommen angewiesen
sind leben die meisten südlich von Rom
Arbeit ist dort rar jedenfalls legale
angemessen bezahlte viele Menschen hier
fürchten die Abschaffung des
bürgereinkommens sprechen von einer
sozialen Bombe
[Musik]
keine zwei Monate ist Georgia Meloni im
Amt mit der weitgehenden Streichung des
Bürgergeldes die sie plant will sie
eines ihrer großen Wahl Versprechen
einlösen arbeiten statt Almosen so ihre
Parole ein symbolischer Triumph für ihre
postfaschistische Partei
die Freiheit ist das Reich zu tun was
man tun muss und ich war immer eine
freie Person und deswegen beabsichtige
ich genau das zu tun was ich tun muss
populistische Rhetorik und einer harte
Rechte seitdem Meloni an der Spitze
steht ist auch die Flüchtlingsfrage
wieder Thema in der Öffentlichkeit damit
lässt sich Stimmung machen ohne dass es
das Budget belastet gerade bei ihren
Stammwählern
etwas Identitätspolitik tut ihr gut
etwas Propaganda gegen Einwanderung
etwas Polemik gegen die politische
Korrektheit
aber auf der anderen Seite muss sie die
Wähler halten die vorher gemäßigt waren
und jetzt für sie stimmen
denn sie sind leicht zu ermüden wenn sie
Unsicherheiten oder extreme sehen
viele kleine Unternehmen sind glücklich
mit melonis Wirtschaftskurs wie hier in
Rimini mario papano hat seit 25 Jahren
ein Restaurant die steigenden
Energiekosten hatten ihn große Sorgen
gemacht dank Meloni sinken sie glaubt er
diese Frau beginnt zu beweisen dass sie
große Fähigkeiten hat
die Kosten sind wieder sehr gesunden von
15.000 Euro auf 6000 sagen wir mal es
geht wieder in Richtung Normalität und
dann macht die Regierung einige
Steuererleichterungen aber bis hier
sieht man die noch nicht
durch die geplante Steuersenkung soll
das Nettoeinkommen seiner Angestellten
steigen ohne dass er etwas tun muss und
er selbst profitiert wenn eine
Pauschalsteuer von 15% auch für höhere
Einkommen von Selbstständigen gilt das
dafür das bürgereinkommen drastisch
eingeschränkt wird findet er richtig
sie haben alle gestohlen hoffen wir dass
diese neue Realität das korrigiert
wenn die Leute Bedarf haben muss ihnen
geholfen werden
aber bei jungen Leuten wir haben gesehen
wie die Schwarzarbeiten wollten weil sie
das Geld vom Staat beziehen
kann mit solchen Beschuldigungen ebenso
wenig anfangen wie mit melonis Politik
sie will arbeiten sagt sie doch einen
Job zu finden in Palermo mit ihren 53
Jahren sei ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit